in the strange world of weird science we
can go from this to this these
engineering students from Lamar
University Texas are literally walking
and somersaulting on water this is
definitely not the pool to do a
cannonball into but how is this
modern-day miracle possible what they've
got in the video is a mixture of
cornstarch and water and this creates a
very special substance called a
non-newtonian fluid if you move slowly
through it it is very much like a liquid
I can very slowly lower my finger down
into it like that and then I can pull it
back out again no problem if I try and
do that quickly it becomes a solid if I
punch it it out that's actually quite
painful it's completely solid if I hit
it but if I go in slowly it's back to
being a liquid so how does mixing just
cornstarch and water create this freaky
fluid if we could zoom into the mixture
we'd see that there are thousands of
tiny corn starch particles evenly
distributed throughout the liquid
mixture if you apply a gentle pressure
then these cornstarch particles can move
over each other and get out of the way
however if you apply a very sudden
pressure you don't give the cornstarch
particles time to move out of the way
and the liquid behaves like a solid and
this is why in the video as long as they
keep moving quickly and impacting the
surface it remains hard if they stop
moving and the molecules have a chance
to slide they sink into it the key thing
is that it will only behave as a solid
for a very short period of time so if
you want to stand on it you've got to
keep moving
weird right